thank you very much for that kind
introduction good afternoon everyone
it's uh it's a pleasure to be here at
Hillsdale College I'm sure this is going
to be a very friendly audience
I was um
we'll see no thank you yeah no I I
appreciate that yes
yes the last well I gave a talk
yesterday to the to some of the grad
students in RJ pastritos class
but before that two weeks ago the last
audience I was in front of was a grand
jury in Washington DC
I was one of the I was one of the 30
people that was subpoenaed from Trump
World
uh regarding the the uh
January 6th and the relationship of my
investigation and other people's
investigation of the election in
November of 2020.
so I spent six and a half hours in front
of a grand jury talking to them about
how I thought China had helped steal the
election
in 2020.
thank you that sort of gratuitous of
course but the um
there were a lot of nodding heads in
that grand jury in Washington DC even in
Washington DC I think people believed
that there was something wrong so
after the first three and a half hours I
thought I can do this all day because
all I was doing was talking about
communist China and what I thought was a
problem
what is a great pleasure to be back at
Hillsdale College someone asked me
earlier in the week where I was going
and I said I was going to the finest
University in America to give a talk
thank you
I'm very proud of what my old colleagues
Larry Arn and Doug Jeffrey and Tim
Casper and Tom West Mickey Craig and R.J
pastritto and so many others have built
here it's a it's a really great honor
and privilege thank you
um before I begin my talk I would like
to make a point that I think needs to be
made
I think you know this but we're living
in very strange times
it's often very difficult to understand
such times
the human eye may look for anomalies
but the human brain look through which
is that which is regular and predictable
it wants to reject anomalies and prefer
instead normalcy
this is one reason that the term
conspiracy theory can gain such traction
in the early days of the cobit pandemic
it was said that it might have come from
the Wuhan Institute of virology
no no that that was just a conspiracy
theory it was said that can't be true
this has heard a lot these days to the
point where it really is the go-to meme
on MSNBC or CNN or any of the mainstream
media when they don't like what is being
said it's a conspiracy theory whether
it's kobit the vaccine election fraud or
anything that deviates from the accepted
narrative
when you examine everything that's going
on today you can't quite make sense of
what is going on you need to ask
yourself the simple question why is this
happening what's going on here is this
all a series of random events or is
there order planning and high government
policy at work
Robert Kennedy mentioned the other night
the event 201 project the so-called
tabletop experiment on how to deal with
the coronavirus pandemic
that included very important people from
within the government and outside the
government April Haynes was there she's
today the Director of National
Intelligence in the mighty
Administration she just happened
to be there Christopher Elias from the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation just
happened to be there George gow from the
Chinese CDC representatives from the
world economic forum and the like
people who'd be influential in the media
now this isn't random this is
this is policy at work strategy at work
people mean to do these things for a
reason there's something going on
and as much as I enjoyed the lectures by
Robert Kennedy and Naomi wolf and I
agree with everything that was said by
them
I just want to remind us once again
these are not mainstream views nowhere
close to it it's not going to be
accepted very far outside this room
unfortunately
nor will anything I have to say be very
mainstream no matter how much people are
waking up to the threat from communist
China
much work needs to be done and I am most
grateful that Hillsdale College is at
the Forefront of presenting these ideas
to a candid world
as chairman of the committee on the
present danger China which I founded
with Steve Bannon and Frank Gaffney in
219. I had the pleasure I have the
pleasure of working with a group of
Scholars writers
intellectuals former military and
intelligence officials academic
policy analysts and the like to
understand what communist China is
trying to do to destroy the United
States
much of what I have to say today
will be the product of four years of
work by the committee to try to
understand the machinations of communist
China and our own government which has
seemingly become very malleable and
subject to manipulation by the CCP
I would humbly argue that for the last
three years the United States
but everything the United States has
experienced has been an exercise in
information political and psychological
warfare aimed at the American people
both from abroad and from forces here at
home
this includes a bio Warfare attack
against the United States although it
was treated even today as something else
and that really is the purpose of my
talk to see if we can understand that
specifically I'd like to discuss the
Chinese Communist party and its
interplay with big Pharma
now I'd like to do three things this
afternoon first I'd like to describe the
Strategic objectives of the Chinese
Communist Party
second I'd like to discuss big farm and
how it has failed the American people
and finally I'd like to discuss how we
think both of these entities are working
to destroy the United States and the
Free World
versus CCP
it has a single goal the control of the
earth and all the peoples of it
three things should inform how we deal
with and think about the Chinese
Communist party and here we are trying
to understand the Chinese Communist
party as they understand themselves
the first is that they have declared a
people's war against the United States
a people's War
they declared this
in May of 2019 against the United States
this was published in the people's daily
which is a media arm of the CCP
it was a signal to the people of China
that an unconventional War would be
waged against the United States
and that they should prepare themselves
for war so it was first a message to the
Chinese people themselves
the reason for this people's war was
that the United States had the temerity
to try to enforce
some kind of ban
some kind of mechanism to stop communist
China
the people's Liberation Army the
industrial Espionage units within it in
private cyber thieves within communist
China from stealing about 500 billion
dollars a year in intellectual property
from the United States
that's five trillion dollars over a
decade the Trump administration had said
so because we have the temerity to ask
them to quit stealing five trillion
dollars of our intellectual property
they declared a people's war on us
that's how they think of us
that whatever we have belongs to them
and I'd also say that people's war was
not just about money
it was also about political control
they believed they had control of the
United States before Donald Trump and
the Maga movement
they had captured the Elites in the west
they thought they had bought them off
major media figures like Rupert Murdoch
were sympathetic to them the Masters of
the Universe on Wall Street Like Larry
Fink at BlackRock or Stephen Schwartzman
at Blackstone were all making billions
of dollars doing business in communist
China
they they the CCP believed they had
complete control of the oligarchs in the
United States that much was clear
the Maga movement and Donald Trump
however represented something different
it represented a genuine Resurgence of
American nationalism
it represented an Awakening for the
American people
the communist movement that has operated
in this country for the better part of a
century
was having a lot of success prior to
Donald Trump
if the primary goal of Communism or a
Communist Revolution is to First
demoralize the American people
which is an absolute requirement for a
Communist Revolution demoralization
Donald Trump represented a
remoralization of the American people
that from the Chinese Communist point of
view could not be tolerated
the United States is the most powerful
nation of the judeo-christian West with
Donald Trump as president the principles
of human freedom and the great
traditions of the Christian West were
being reborn
for that reason the Chinese Communist
Party must have believed that it must be
destroyed or at minimum Donald Trump
needed to be destroyed politically
within six months of their Declaration
of a people's award the covid-19 virus
was spreading throughout the world it
matters little whether it was
intentionally leaked from a lab or not
what is clear is that they allowed it to
spread throughout the world knowing the
harm it would cause and just as a
practical matter
even if it were an intentional attack in
war deception matters and even an
intentional attack would require that it
looked like an accident
as I'll discuss a little later
but it was always going to be presented
as the possibility of a lamp leak
now
again regardless
covid-19 was used as a bio weapon
against the United States
which leads me to the second point in
this section
when you're trying to understand
communist China
you really need to understand their
belief in unrestricted Warfare
there was a famous book by two Colonels
in 1999 there were colonels of course of
the people's Liberation Army and they
wrote a book called unrestricted Warfare
and it's been a popular document that I
and my colleagues on the committee on
the danger point to
because it's one of the ways to
understand China and how they think
about policy and statecraft
in the book The Two Colonels believed
that war between China
and the United States is inevitable
and the PRC they believe must be
prepared
if they are to win to engage in whatever
means are necessary to achieve this and
they say
the variable means to achieve this
Victory include the use of economic
Warfare cyber warfare information
Warfare political Warfare they use this
phrase terrorism bio Warfare and the
like
they write that they tell the world this
in 1999.
Wars as we know are fought on
battlefields on the Seas
but yes today they are also fought
online in the media in boardrooms and
classrooms and in Laboratories
their purpose in writing this document
which was very well known in China and
outside of China
was to lay down a marker with U.S policy
makers
that nothing was going to be out of
bounds when it comes to how the PRC
viewed the United States
they wanted to make sure the PRC was
capable of Waging War that they were
committing committed doing so whenever
and wherever it took
so for all the Commerce we in the United
States May engage in with the PRC we
ought to have no illusions that they see
themselves as our enemy
and an enemy that they are allowed to do
anything they want to because after all
from their point of view they're in a
war with us
this leads me to the third part of my
section on Chinese the Chinese Communist
party and that's work that's been
extensively done by my colleague on the
committee on the present danger J.R
Nyquist
and he's really done extensive work in
promoting a secret speech that was given
in 2003
and it deals with what the Chinese
Communists think of as the problem of
America
and it was articulated in this speech by
the Chinese defense minister General
shihoshin
he gave it to members of the pilot
Bureau
and I'm going to focus a bit on it today
because I think it is one of the most
underappreciated documents that are
Intel in this community has and does not
highlight
and I think you'll see where I'm going
with this
um
As I Lay this out
he's talking to the people within the
pilot Bureau who are going to be
planning out the future of Chinese
strategy
and he's taking a long-term view the way
the Chinese typically do
as he's laying out the problems for them
to deal with he is referencing Nazi
Germany first in World War II of course
he says
about Nazi Germany the following are the
fundamental causes of their defeat the
Nazis
first they had too many enemies all at
once
as they did not adhere to the principles
of a limit eliminating enemies one at a
time second there were two impetuous
lacking the patience and perseverance
required for Great accomplishments
third when the time came for them to be
ruthless they turned out to be too soft
therefore leaving troubles that
resurfaced later on
so just for perspective shiho Shin
believes the Nazis were inherently as he
says too soft
to win the Second World War
so he lays out what ought to have been
their strategy he says let's presume
that back when Germany and Japan had
been able to keep the United States
neutral
and had fought a protracted War step by
step on the Soviet front
if they'd adopted this approach gained
some time to advance their research
eventually succeeded in obtaining the
technology of nuclear weapons and
missiles
and launched surprise attacks against
the United States and the Soviet Union
using them then the United States and
the Shelby Union would not have been
able to defend themselves and would have
had to surrender
little Japan he says in particular made
an egregious mistake in launching the
sneak attack on Pearl Harbor this attack
not hit the vital parts of the United
States
instead it dragged the United States
into the war into the ranks of the
gravediggers that eventually buried the
German and Japanese fascists